[Music]
so I'm Shalini I head up Android TV
thank you very much for joining us in
this session around developing for
Android TV so as Rick alluded to in the
keynote this morning the home is really
undergoing some major disruptions
starting with broadband getting better
to the homes leading to more connected
devices OTT services really becoming
mainstream in the home and voice
technologies creating very simple
interfaces with which to connect to
different devices within your home
having said that we still find that
people's favorite place to come home to
is still the TV people are watching TV
more than they have ever done before
more than phones more than tablets it is
TVs that people come back home to and
more and more these TVs are your gateway
into the connected home in addition as I
mentioned OTT services are one of the
ways people are watching content on
their TVs and in fact this data is us
data but this is actually true worldwide
64% of users have at least one
subscription that they are consuming on
their TVs and I would say probably in
this room you have at least more than
two and like I said this is a global
phenomena and that is really the beauty
of Android TV it provides one place for
users to watch content whether it's
coming from their live TV or whether
it's coming from an OTT app and one
place to play their favorite games
powered by the Play Store and that is
really the momentum that Android TV is
creating many of you may know or may not
that we have two tea
that we offer to our partners the retail
tier is what we offer to our OEMs
including Sony TV and streaming devices
and this is powered by a Android forward
user experience that showcases assistant
cast and the Play Store as well as
YouTube the second tier is what we offer
to our operators which in addition to
the beauty of what we provide on the
retail tier also offers them an
experience that they can provide to
their subscribers in what we call the
operator mode because of this phenomenal
flexibility and of course the power of
Android which is what Android TV resides
on we are seeing phenomenal success in
the market and I'm really happy to
announce six of the top ten Smart TV
OEMs have signed up with Android TV and
worldwide we have signed up a hundred
and forty plus operator partners thank
you because of this momentum and thanks
to you and all of your support we are
also happy to announce a thousand plus
streaming content providers including
Amazon Prime which is now available
broadly on all Android TV platforms so
we have really leaned in to our app
developers and 5,000 plus Android TV
apps that are prevalent in the TV app
store and so with that success I'm going
to hand it over to Unger who's gonna
talk a little bit more about all the
exciting things that are coming in
Android TV and how you can use them for
your own success
Thank You Shalini hi my name is Anwar
Hanif I lead product for Android TV
ecosystem and integrations you know I I
wanted to share a memorable personal
professional a moment that I had a
couple of months ago I had my 70 year
old father visit and I explained to him
how he could control his Android TV
using his voice using a Google home
device for the first time in his life I
can't I won't ever forget the expression
that he had for the first time in his
life he felt like technology understood
him as opposed to the other way around
he without the need for a remote control
he could control his TV he could control
his lights all with the simplicity of
his voice now now on the other hand for
my adorable but mildly annoying
seven-year-old daughter voice control TV
and lights creates a whole different
story that's a story for another time at
Google whether you're 70 or
seven-year-old or somewhere in between
at Google we're committed to making the
lives of our users better with
technology one way we're doing this is
by using the Google assistant to become
a helpful backdrop to your lives helping
connect you cutting connecting you with
the other technology in your lives and
in this new world of connected devices
and technology at home Android TV is the
platform that Google is developing for
the biggest and most important screen at
home ever since TV was invented it
served one key purpose which is helping
us watch media with the Google assistant
we have the opportunity to change and
evolve the role of TV in our lives to
make it more helpful and help us become
a conduit to accessing other
technologies at home
this is the direction that we want to
take Android TV and this vision can only
become successful if it's shared by our
partners
our ecosystem only with your help can we
make this reality true we heard your
feedback we've spoken to several of you
and we started to act on that feedback
number one we heard that you want us to
help it make it easier for you to
develop apps on Android TV at the same
time you wanted to make it easier for
you to participate in the assistant
Google assistant ecosystem you want to
make opportunity you want us to help you
with opportunities to make your content
shine in our platform and you want us to
help you fuel your innovation by helping
you commercialize and make commerce
easier on Android TV I'm excited to
share with you a couple of examples of
the things that we've done in the past
year as well as new initiatives and new
features that we're launching coming
soon
Android steam Android TV strength is in
the range and breadth of devices and
form factors that the devices at
different price points that's available
today but we've also heard that as a
developer this very the variability in
devices can make it a little bit more
challenging in terms of being able to
address these devices earlier this year
we launched reference + this is a
program by which we simplify and reduce
the variability in hardware so that as a
developer you can more easily X address
the target devices that you're
addressing on Android TV reference +
devices are also Google assistant ready
this ensures a consistent performance
and behavior across devices from
multiple manufacturers today we're
working with 10 TV manufacturers and
we'll be working with more over time
with the proliferation of streaming
content creating a great media discovery
experience is something that we found to
be extremely critical for our users as
well as for our develop
verse earlier Android TV launched a user
experience which gave users multiple
options by which they can access their
content including the ability to jump in
right into their favorite content from
the home screen many partners have
embraced this channels and have built
their and and are starting to see great
engagement and response and impact
because of embracing channels some of
our partners are seeing up to 70%
increase in watch time and up to 78%
increase in views by embracing channels
users sustain more engaged and create
more opportunities for our media
partners to monetize through this
engagement but we're not stopping there
what I'd like to talk about next is some
of the new features that we're
introducing in the coming year the
Google assistant is built into Android
TV and we've enabled users to it control
their on-demand content using voice
today we're lending our voice to more of
our media partners coming soon a system
knows what's on live TV and will allow
you to use your voice to instantly
switch over to live content that you
have playing on your TV Philo is one of
the first partners that are working with
us and I would invite you to stop over
at our sandbox to see a live demo as the
media and app ecosystem for TFR Android
TV grows we know it's important for us
to draw to create opportunities for you
or ecosystem partners to drive discovery
of the app and content that you're
developing to help with that we're
developing new ways by which we can
curate and highlight high quality
content on the home screen and this is
supported by our editorial team at
Google Play expect to see more coming
out soon in the space our user insights
indicate that users a lot more in
gage in the app search discovery and
browsing process when they really
understand the content experience and
media within the apps that are available
on the Play Store that's why today I'm
excited to announce that we're launching
a complete refresh of the Play Store on
Android TV coming later this year the
new Play Store offers the much more
immersive discovery experience where the
the media a medium content experiences
are highlighted more prominently and
creates a much more engaged Discovery
experience for our users
lastly we heard from you your driving
innovation and your investing in content
what what and sustaining that innovation
and investment requires fuel this is one
of the most popular requests that we
received from our ecosystem we need to
make it easier for users to buy and
subscribe on Android TV later this year
we'll be rolling out an updated user
experience that brings the best of
Google Play building on to Android TV
this includes a simplified user
experience that that simplifies commerce
on TV including functionalities such as
subscribe and install this will allow
your users to not only install an app
but also subscribe to your service or
from the Play Store secondly we're
introducing pin functionality this will
further streamline the purchasing
process on Android TV and make it much
more easier without the need for a
password purchases on Android TV will
now be smoother faster and more seamless
so what I spoke about today I spoke
about a couple of different things one
we're tying in and leaning into the
Google assistant ecosystem number two
we're highlighting and creating
opportunities to highlight the content
that you're creating within from our
from the ecosystem and lastly we're
simplifying commerce on Android TV these
are just a few of the ways by which
we're bringing the best of Google on to
Android TV as we move towards richer
Google assistant experiences in the home
Android TV as the largest screen at home
is a critical pillar of Google strategy
in in the in the living room getting
here has been an incredible effort and I
thank you for all that effort and all
the commitment that he had to help us
getting here I'm really excited about
what we are introducing today and all
the innovations that we have baking in
the labs I really look forward to
working with you and look forward to
seeing what we can innovate with you
together with that I'll hand it over to
Ben who helped us walk through how some
of these innovations can be used in your
apps thank you thanks anwar hello
everyone I'm Benjamin Baxter I was on
developer relations as a developer
advocate for Android TV I recently
joined as an engineer on the internet on
the Android TV team I want to talk about
all the things are more just said but
how you can do them your app today
but first I'm really pleased to announce
some adoption numbers for Android OS we
now have over 80% of Android TV devices
running new getting above by the end of
the year we should see 60% running Oreo
this is amazing with Oreo we decoupled
the launcher from the OS this enables us
to update faster and give users better
experiences much easier you don't have
to wait for the next Android operating
system just to get the newest features
let's dive into these features the three
things on were talked about were the
assistant how to bring your content
forward on the home screen
how to make your app easier for commerce
let's start with the assistant I'm
really a cloud really about really
plowed to announce three main things one
watch-actions live TV and playback
controls watch actions are way for you
to say hey Google I want to watch
adventures infinity war across all of
our surfaces web mobile and especially
TV we're able to showcase your app as if
as a platform to watch that content all
you have to do as an app developer is
supply your content to Google and we can
say hey this app has your content we've
updated that to support live TV so now
if you have a complex electronic
programming guide an EPG
you can submit that as part of your
content catalog and we can surface this
live TV content across all of our
surfaces in addition we've updated all
of our documentation about these watch
actions
next with search we've also added
operator integrations so if you're a TV
operator you can have custom actions
present it to the user such as DVR and
record now as a user they can still
select more options and see your app
that has that content in search lastly I
want to talk about playback controls
we've made them even easier with
exoplayer for playback controls you need
to have a media session what you're able
to do now is listen for callbacks from
the user such as when they say hey
Google skip forward five minutes you end
up getting these callbacks through a
media session call back with exoplayer
we made this easier by connecting those
two together
what's dive car further here we're
making the media session which just
takes in a context in a tag and then we
set it to active and if you have other
things need to set like the media
session state or what your players doing
set that at this time as well once you
have an instance to your media session
go ahead and find your exoplayer
instance with those two you can create a
media session connector this is a new
class from an extension library from the
media from exoplayer
here we create a media session connector
and we pass in that media session
instance later we just call set player
and we give it the exoplayer instance
the media session connector handles all
of those playback controls and all the
callbacks for you if you do need to
customize it it's super simple you can
add in all the extra customization you
need say you have a music playlist and
you want to customize the cueing system
you can do that super simple with this
so to wrap that up we've implemented new
live TV integrations we've updated our
documentation and watch actions and we
may playback controls even easier with
exoplayer let's talk about the home
screen this is where your sh content can
really shine the first thing you notice
as a user is the app the app shows up
and represents your branding and your
content with a banner we've discovered
some best practices and we just want to
go over them quickly here we have this
beautiful app banner best practice my
new favorite app however the banner
matters in this case we're reusing the
mobile icon and we notice that the app
icon becomes very scrin scrunched and
hard to see this could lead to a bad
user experience and not represent your
branding wealth on the opposite side of
the spectrum here we have an image
that's too large and gets scaled and
might be blurry you really want to have
a banner that's 320 by 180 you also want
to put that banner in the xhdpi folder
if you put it in just drawable it's
gonna be recognized as an mdpi folder
and this could lead to scaling and buzz
and blurriness with your image also note
we do reuse your banner in certain
contexts depending where the user is and
we need to represent your branding we
reuse that banner across the home screen
so the homescreen real fast to find what
amar talked about earlier really
comprises of three things channels these
are rows that you can surface content to
the user in addition there's also a play
next row that system managed and you can
add content there for the users to
quickly hop back in finally you can have
video previews for example here we have
an immersive preview from Red Bull and
we've seen increased engagement from
apps that support video previews
how does this work under the covers your
app is going to talk to the launcher
through a content provider you can send
over any data games music video that
your app has and the launcher is going
to store that in the TV provider
database since we're using the content
provider we're able to do some
optimizations that are pretty cool if
you use the content provider before you
may be used to content provider
operations we can optimize all of these
operations when we go to update the home
screen by doing this all in bulk so for
example we make a call to our back-end
and we get a list of content that we
need to add to the home screen we can
look through that content and look
through what's in our channel and say
hey here's a bunch of new content that
we need to add and create a new new
operation to add that content this
creates an operation that we can add to
our list of operations well vice versa
we can also say these pieces of content
need to be removed and click three
delete operations finally whatever is
left we should just update and make a
bunch of update operations when we're
done we can apply all of these in batch
this allows us to have one transaction
and optimizes performance with the home
screen I'm also happy to announce that
with Android X we made this easier for
you you don't have to worry about
content providers when using Android X
let's take a look here we have a preview
channel helper and then this helper you
can add all the metadata you need and
lastly you can add the logo the logo
should be an 80 by 80 picture and as the
the system we're going to apply a mask
and show a final image that might be
different than what you supplied think
of it like adaptive icons for mobile but
not quite the same what matters most
that you supply an 80 by
image for us to use once you have your
channel you just add published channel
and this does everything is one
transaction for you no more content
provider once you get the channel ID you
should store this for synchronizing
later where you might want to use those
batch operations from a content provider
next I want to talk about the play next
row over the past couple years I've
worked with a lot of apps and TV shows
really shine on the play next row this
is an example from the DC Universe app
where they have strong indications to
watched Young Justice as a user you
could be halfway through a show here
we're ten minutes into a 21 minute
episode and the leaf and when you leave
as an app you can add strong strong
notes and UI indicators hey you're
halfway through in addition you can add
this content to the play next row one
thing we noticed is that there's a piece
of metadata called last engagement time
this sounds pretty trivial it represents
the last time stamp a user or an app has
has interacted with that piece of
content here for example when the user
pauses the show that should be the
timestamp for last engagement time when
the user goes back in and they finish
watching the show and they see the
credits this is a great time to add a
next episode to the play next row here
the DC adds the next episode we're able
to give strong visual indicators to the
user this is the next episode here's
where you left off but the time stamp
for last engagement time should change
this should be the time the credits came
up this is technically the last time the
user has interacted with that season if
you think of that as a season last
engagement time makes more sense since
they haven't interacted with the next
episode the last part of the life cycle
of a TV show is new episode so a new
piece of content for Young Justice
hasn't come out yet they'll be the aired
at a later date so user has not
interacted with that yet you can still
add that to the home screen and set the
last engagement time to the time when
the episode is aired the launcher sees
of that times in the future and will
handle the content accordingly
there's a bunch of pros and cons and
do's and don'ts the quote the key rule
of thumb is if a user interaction a
piece of content that's fair game for
the home screen lastly I want to talk
about how to make your app more friendly
and be prepared for when these changes
come for commerce later such as Elmer
talked about mainly it comes down to
distribute your app in the Play Store
then you need to do a few things one in
your manifest file declare that you use
the Leanback feature to make sure you
have the Leanback intent filter for your
main activity the last thing you need to
do is when you're in your Play Store
listing go to pricing and distribution
and select this checkbox what this does
is this enables a process that sends
your app to the Play Store review team
they're going to review your app for
simple things like d-pad support app
crashes and give your report if it if it
doesn't support this this helps ensure
that we have a basic bar of quality for
the Android TV apps we have documented
what those checks are on on
developer.android.com by having your app
on the Play Store when we support
features like subscriber install later
this year you're already ahead of the
game and can start making money faster
so - in conclusion then there are three
things we've been focusing on are making
your app easier to integrate the
assistant such as with live TV and watch
actions having your content really shine
on the home screen requires a little
effort with your banner and making
channels and easier channels and play
next easier for your app and lastly with
the Play Store making sure you opt in
will enable your app to be discovered on
the Android TVs with that Lillian is
going to talk about some of the cool
things they've been doing thank you
Thank You Man
so hi I'm noe from canal class I'm one
of the founder of the hundred team in
Canada
and today I'm going to show you what we
have achieved with application my canal
on the unha-3 platform so catalyst is a
pay-tv leader in France but we are also
present on many part of the world so
especially in Europe like in Switzerland
Poland but also in many places in Africa
and also in Asia like in Yamaha and in
Vietnam my canal is a canal trees over
the top platform and it's a video of
services we provide like TV channels
with a feature called start over it's a
way to let our users seek in the past of
what has been broadcasted on our live TV
channels we have also VOD content from
our partner networks also we have on a
CD channel well as with the serviced
sorry and T VOD service to bring the
newest content for our users and it's an
buy or rent sama so our application is
video centric and we needed a great
platform to to build to build them and
with support all these tunnels of the
industry starting from the supporter of
h.264 media codecs and formats h.265 and
we were thrilled to to note that in the
new Curie's the open source even codex
is made available and we can build upon
it now also
HDR 10 plus is on the way
so video content will be even better on
the platform for less bandwidth we are
also pleased today to announce that we
provide for the first time 4k contents
in fact my canal you need to be in
exclusivity 420 Sony TV sets for now so
it's really a great time to greet video
application on the Unruh TV platform so
as I said we are video centric
application and we did it to to build
upon a great player and we chose to use
extra player and I will tell you why so
it's the heart of the experience of our
services and we needed to handle many
technologies on inside application and
as you can see on this slide on exactly
your handles many many features and
capabilities from the management of the
area timelines media composition the
support of the standards of the adaptive
streaming so there is a lot of
containers available there is a lot of
captioning technologies and also hexa
player gives you nice extensions to make
your work easier for example media
section to plug assistant to the player
and some other one so here's some
highlights of what we have used inside
my canal so it makes sense to you to use
exactly inside our application so I will
describe for use case of the use of
extra player so to start off media
sources is the entry point of your video
playback and it will handle all the 12
oz teams you need in my canal we used -
media sources smooth streaming media
sources and a cherish media sources so
each media sources have a factory in
with exoplayer
and it's really easy to to instantiate
them and everything is routed with the
you area of the manifest you want to
play
the factories of the media sources from
enterprise we powerful because you can
customize it for example you may want to
have a custom manifest passer to handle
the feature that is not entered by
default by exoplayer you can also adjust
your position of your life life with
streams on your on the left TV channels
and you have also allowed the ah policy
that you collect you can customize and
here it's a great feature to handle the
load errors you may in control the ring
your playback for example your manifest
can describe video checks that are not
completely available on your server and
you may get for example some 412 HTTP
you know and you don't you don't want to
make your playback through in some areas
so you have to keep in light you may
need to retry the loading of your trunks
so customizing your alodia policy solve
this problem ok one also a powerful
feature of this appear is media
composition and the interactive media at
the extension from is a player use it
and it's really useful to concatenate
your content with the add video content
in a single timeline so how you how you
use the extension first you need the
player and also you have to interchange
the email as rodeo where you will put
the vast as you where I needed to
retrieve all the ads content and also
all the ads impression you have to
handle give to the AMIA as a player
because during the playback the image ad
text extension will handle all the ads
impression for you
then Nvidia molasses the content you
want to play and next just instantiate
your admin users and give it to it want
your content media source and also you
need to give it to it play of you
because he makes the email at the
extension we provide for user
interactive UI offer for your on your
ads own people your player and you're
ready to have a nice playback of three
roles mid Wars and password inside your
in your video and everything is handled
nicely you will not have any buffering
time between the transition of each
videos thanks to some magic because of
player caching ok let's talk about
doramin and we tip it's a fad from
supports the two main demon agents that
the interest that the content owners
industry trust it's Google Widevine
and Microsoft free ready and thanks to
this to dear Emma agent we are able to
provide 4k content extra player gives
you a great tools to manage difference
so you have media dynamic interface
which is exposed by extra player and you
have a callback so execute three
requests which will be tricked by by the
direction in which is in the work during
the video decoding and when it's trigger
other you just have to route which of
the two deranged what you want you will
focus on power if you get a white vinyl
unique ID you may want to request your
white van license server and the same
same thing for the PID one you you may
want to route your license request to
the good server depending of the sender
you you you may want to use one or
another derangement it's up to you
so how we start to play back with the
ramen so as you saw we need our dear
Emma called back then we have to inject
it to adherence to manager the DRM
session manager will handle all the
different session that the playback we
need and will handle all the requests of
license you need in such a player and
inject it in the country style of
exoplayer
and that's it your playback is ready if
you want to find out more about
exoplayer just follow this link and i
recommend you to watch the io 17
efficient opening the player where all
the architecture is very well described
it ok in my canal we have also embraced
all the features here on treaty platform
offers to us and first we embrace the
home screen we've added a lot of TV
channels inside my canal and it's really
really powerful because it gives us the
freedom to let our user customize the
experience has been as they want and it
gives the ability to our user to find
the content just by one click on the
home screen we use also the nice and
smooth transition of the Tibetan show
and did your previews so as you see even
if your picture concerns are not to the
same ratio has a video the launcher
organ rhythm
handles it with a nice and smooth
animation
of course I make analysis and trading
and we use it to essentially handle the
playback controls of the of the pleasure
of my canal we use it to launch any
playback we want for example if you want
to watch the newest movies on my canal
we just have to ask a assistant and we
play automatically for you but one of
the powerful feature is the combination
of the power of assistant and our life
TV streams as I said earlier we have the
start of a feature and for any live TV
channels a my canal we can sit into the
past up to 8 hours that means we can ask
assistant to start from the beginning of
any content we want and if you have your
great TV shot which is already on air
you can ask a system to start from the
beginning all you may want also to ask
assistant to to bring back to the first
episode in this case if you want that's
not it
we want it to push the unreachable form
to the twits limit and I will show you
two great feature we we did inside my
canal so first one is what we call the
expert model it's it's a service for our
life for our live events especially for
spots where we bring that is real-time
statistics for our users so it's
available for soccer rugby golf and also
for Formula One and motor country
we've also added for motor country a new
feature which we provide a 360 - c'mon
behind any bikes of racers and you can
inside your microphone we TV watch the
progress of Red Rover at any angle it's
very intensive and very very interesting
okay so next one is multi-level mutual
Ivan he's pushing the limit of the
untreated TV platform so in this example
you have four instances of extra player
and we have to trick a lot of things to
make the playback very seamlessly the
dalmatian are powered by the constraint
set animation we also have to
synchronize all the other business
overall zero player at the same time and
we have to lower the adaptation of the
player which are not in front of the our
users and higher-ups the one which is
the high which is which is done in the
sorry so to cover it with that and not
any devices can handle multi live and we
had to determine which one is capable of
or not so exit player sorry except
player give you a little column want the
media codec utility to give you how many
instances a device can handle but do not
trust it at 100% because first a device
can lie to you and also you may have
another application using any codecs
behind your application so it's a little
bit it's a little confusing but it's
also a nice way to determine how many
instances a player device can handle so
that's it thank you everybody I think so
well thank you all for coming today
we've covered a lot of stuff Shalini
started talking about the momentum and
how we keep growing year-over-year as
Android TV on work came in and talked
about where we're investing making your
content more discoverable how we're
doubling down on Google Play billing in
the Play Store
I talked about some best practices and
Lillian talked about how we applied them
in his own app so I'm sure you have tons
of questions please come next door the
sandbox will happily answer them if you
have an app and you want it to be
reviewed and you talk to engineers and
the UX team from Android TV come over to
app reviews we're right across the way
and brick signup and it's easy coming in
so thank you very much for coming today
this would not be possible without you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]